how old are you dude you got about as
much testosterone as I do what do you do
for a living
you sure you can lift them boxes I'm not
saying this to make fun of you you and I
share similar struggles low teeth how do
you know these three
yo good for you dude you're like white
meat dog how long have you guys been
dating respectively holy [__] that's the
[__] move bruh he got her when she
was she was too stupid to know how hot
she was
for a stop agent at 15. you guys are
married I hope God damn dude you acting
like you got leverage son you
know because you're a UPS driver you can
steal your truck one day drive away from
you be like what was I thinking this
whole time ah dude she loves you it's
dumb on her bar but she loves you